let's jump into this first story we have
this from The Daily Mail Chinese spy
balloon the size of three buses is
spotted floating over Montana for days
as U.S mobilizes F-22 Raptors to
intercept Biden wanted to shoot it down
but Pentagon advised him not to because
of falling debris they say defense
officials discuss shooting out of the
sky on Wednesday while it was above
Billings Montana but decided instead to
monitor it closely F-22 Raptors were
sent from Nellis Air Force Base in
southern Nevada but they did not engage
with the object now you got this picture
here of a tiny dot but we got you we got
you look at this thing it's got solar
panels that's like solar panels right
look at that so what you're looking at
is a technology package those are
sensors yeah
um this is a trial balloon those are
sense like it's it's literally a spy
balloon right but I think the reason
they did it was to see what they can get
away with and they got away with a lot
they're getting away with whatever they
want this thing could be carrying what
if this was a bomb what if it was some
kind of weapon or what if hey what if it
causes Havana syndrome well of course
keep in mind that what they're doing is
they're also judging our response and
that's your point with the trial
building exactly so they're going to see
how long did it take them to scramble
Fighters how long did it take for the
balloon to stay there before we
scrambled anything up uh what's the is
there a diplomatic response what's the
Diplomatic are they going to put
sanctions they're going to put tariffs
keep in mind that you have to look at
through at all of this through the lens
of Taiwan because we know that that will
be
potentially another military flash point
if we continue our escalation in well
they just they just went into high alert
right scrambling they started uh
mobilizing their their air defense they
just scrambled a couple of days ago yeah
because this has been happening since uh
really since Biden got in office
basically yo I think this this is a bad
sign if uh China's recently China
mobilized a bunch of jets and warships
and they've been escalating firing
Rockets over Taiwan Taiwan is now
mobilizing it defenses what if this spy
balloon is literally to track our
response to Taiwan and what they're
doing and they're trying to gather as
much information as possible well the
the Spy balloon itself and we have to go
into what what does America have in
Montana that could be interesting to the
CCP and I guarantee you it's not just
Farmland by the way is it a four-letter
acronym um it is uh what which I can
mean ICBM yes ICBM exactly so uh the the
Air Force Base that when you watch a
movie and you see the nuclear silos and
the nuclear missiles pop out one of the
the three Fields where we have them
about 150 nuclear long-range nuclear
tipped missiles the intercontinental
ballistic missiles that were within
range of China and these are not the
only ones but these are this is a key
component of the U.S nuclear Triad which
is located in Montana specifically
that's why I think we may have been on
here before once and I was talking you
were talking about which state would you
want to be if
um the U.S fell apart and I said well
Montana has nukes so you know yeah I'd
pick Montana it'd be one of the most
powerful countries in the world easily
U.S current military installations in
Montana we have three radar sites in
Carter County we have Fort William Henry
Harrison in Lewis and Clark County and
Maelstrom Air Force Base and Cascade so
maelstrom's the one that has it and and
so of course what they're going to be
doing is and and now it's also
interesting because of course you know
China has pi satellites the same way
that we have spy satellites so we have
to look at why are they using a balloon
to do this when obviously so during uh
the Cold War for example the U.S had the
um the YouTube spy plane this was okay
the Dragon Lady so there was a a pilot
who was shot down at one point became a
pow situation he was eventually turned
over we had over flights they had over
flights but then that's largely turned
toward and we still do it but it's
largely torn towards a satellite game at
this point
um they're actually funny enough there
was a there was an episode of Rogan
recently where they were talking about
the NGA and I think it was with Tim
Dillon and each of them weren't really
sure what the NGA did it's well spy
satellites that's what the NDA does
National geospatial information agency
and so our intelligence agency and so
the Chinese have this this capability as
well signals imagery Etc so if you want
something that's that what you know
people looking at this as high but from
a a an intelligence collection from
platform this is actually low yeah I'm
wondering is it the kind of thing where
we have such high-tech uh surveillance
things that the low-tech stuff can get
through now like you know that kind of
thing where you have Radars but you
can't see the thing right in front of
your face like lidar maybe we talked
about I mean it could be they could be
mapping the nuclear silence you know
that famous story where they did like a
war game with the old guard and the new
guard and then the old guys won and
they're like how did you do it and
they're like we sent a motorcycle
Courier with the information so you
couldn't intercept it and I was like
that's the big deal what I'm what I'm
thinking about this balloon is what's
worrying to me let me know what you
think
if China's getting ready to attack and
they know U.S the U.S will respond to an
attack on Taiwan then they're not
concerned like a criminal who is going
to rob a liquor store is not concerned
that he's breaking the law with guns
because he's planning on breaking the
law in whole if China's planning and
engaging in a military operation they
know will create conflict the U.S they
don't care if we get mad about a balloon
they want to know what we're mobilizing
and where now it's kind of an
interesting point that you make because
we know that they have the balloon there
we know that we send f-22s up the
question is is there something that the
US government isn't telling us that
China was also doing that they were
trying to check the track the response
to our silos
was there would there be a Cyber attack
of Taiwan would there be something that
may maybe not rise to the level of
kinetic
um like a blockade or a missile strike
and they were trying to test our
response to see if we went nuclear with
this but that being said this might be a
trial balloon right for when they do
launch their attack in Taiwan and
they're going to want to gauge our
response with these Air Force bases
within in Montana I've got a feeling
they were in Canada uh along with the
Canadian government's approval and it
got blown off course
I think that might be what happened well
I mean look they're currently in there
so basically Canada is operating as a
CCP they're currently in the United
States with U.S government approval
yeah we've been here for like what three
days we could have we should have shot
and I think everybody knows that if that
if president Trump were in there we're
in the white house I mean we would have
found out this thing because something
would have blown up in the sky and then
we would have gotten a tweet saying
something like I mean just imagine the
Tweet chairman she had burst your bubble
yeah so so yeah I mean we have this
absolutely gone the U.S state department
has reportedly summoned the Chinese
Ambassador over the Chinese spy balloon
which has been detected flying over
Northern Montana oh boy maybe another
strongly worded letter will come next no
no no no no no no a physical wag of the
finger to his face even worse even
though they're really going to give it
to him
in their boots remember when Anthony
blinken was talking to China and they
just told him to shut the up so that was
in Anchorage Alaska yep and they went up
and and blinken went in there I remember
this because they they were whenever
you're you're holding one of these
Summits like this and he met with young
Jay Chou which is sort of the
interlocutor for for the CCP he he's the
former Chinese Minister of Foreign
Affairs but he's currently on the pilot
Borough and even though he's the former
Minister he's sort of the point man for
when it comes to International Affairs
young nature and he just ate his lunch
he just completely ate his lunch and
Lincoln was saying we're gonna set the
new normal with China and we're going to
establish the new norms and and put this
all right all of those messy Trump years
are going to behind us and he basically
told him that you're nothing to us he
treated him like he treated him like a
student like a little boy almost like he
was he basically just said you have no
power here you know the old uh like Lord
of the Rings he said you're not are
you're not you're not negotiating from
from a position of power that's right
the U.S has nothing
amazing you have nothing we have
everything and so every day and I just I
want people to look at this by balloon
and I want uh particularly older members
of the audience who remember the US
during the Cold War and remember our
response to uh the Cuban Missile Crisis
or our response to anything that that
had to do with a direct threat to the
American Homeland
this would not have been tolerated for
even one second during the Cold War but
today we're told oh it's not that big of
a deal don't worry about it I think
they've done it a few times already and
you know this this package doesn't even
it's not about the sensors that are on
this it's about the US response from a
political and a military obviously a
military being directed by the political
perspective that if we don't have the
political will to defend the Homeland
against any threat that just shows once
again that we are distracted we are
being worn thin in places like Eurasia
where we're currently flooding what
tanks money every single day
fighting Russia in this proxy war that
we're in with Russia and now China is
considering and Professor mircheimer has
talked about this China is considering
opening up what would essentially be for
us a second front and a two-front global
company like World War II We're not
gonna be able to handle it
uh meanwhile and it's not so Israel just
attacked Iran the other day too so I
mean how many fronts do you want this is
like going to be a legit World War it's
funny they talk about World War one and
two and it's like Europe World War II
you had Japan you know Imperial Japan
but it's kind of like that was its own
thing and there were some cons you know
there was obviously concern with the US
and U.S expansion and stuff like that so
it was like World War but you know large
portions of the world weren't actively
involved that's why you have first world
second world third world et cetera but
this one this time it's gearing up to be
what you know today is today is the 80th
anniversary of the end of Stalingrad
today wow 80 80 years ago today the
bloodiest conflict in human history
ended the surrender of the German six
Army the field Marshal paulus became the
highest ranking pow I think in in
potentially all of of World War II
um when when he surrendered at
Stalingrad but you know two million
people civilians and Military died in
the span of five months the World War II
the it was air power you know know the
reason it wasn't on every on every piece
of soil is because the B-52s couldn't
reach or I guess was it to be was it the
B-52 at that point and the massive bomb
they saw like local range you know
Britain to Germany back or and then the
V2 Rockets Germany to Britain we didn't
now we have lasers from space we have
inner orbital bomb Strikers you know
there's nowhere is safe on earth now
well it's it's it's it's all about this
right this is exactly what they're
focused on because when when Putin gets
up there and says this isn't World War
II anymore and we have the ability to
strike anywhere on the planet uh that is
the reality of nuclear war and that's
why the Cold War stayed cold because
there's an interesting dichotomy where
obviously nuclear weapons are the most
powerful weapon that's ever been created
but they also have this this secondary
nature whereby in it creates for almost
a more peaceful War because more
peaceful world because if everyone has
the ability to destroy everyone else and
end all of a civilization it's like
every buddy standing in the world
holding hand grenade with the pin out
and your thumbs down so all right well
I'm not going to drop my hand grenade
you're not going to drop yours either
and then we're all just stuck that way
and then what Pro and then we have to
deal with each other trying to like
non-proliferation agreements we're like
Hey we're gonna break down all our
nuclear weapons but no one ever does it
is that the thing I mean why would you
you put down your hand grenade right no
you put your you put yours down like no
let's do it at the same time at the same
time he may or may not be building hand
grenades but let's just set our hand
grenades down right exactly and so and
so my point is it's it's not in any
country's strategic interest to do this
it much has been brought up of the fact
that Ukraine did have some of some
nuclear weapons uh at the fall of the
Soviet Union and that which were later
transported to Russia and now that's why
they don't have them during this
conflict thanks for watching this clip
from the timcast IRL podcast hang out
with us live Monday through Friday at 8
pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time